you don't talk to me like that my bad
behavior that's just insulting please
I'm an adult
that's just rude and belittling
no I have dairy I was Furious Christine
Brown snaps back at Cody after his not
so nice words when they were still
together I think just because I'm so
more grounded in I just like my I just
like me and I like my life so much
better now in the one-on-one Sister
Wives special on TLC the former couple
watches back Clips showcasing The
Fallout of their spiritual marriage
which includes some harsh words from
Cody you're blaming me for me being
turned off by your behavior the reason
I'm not attracted is because she's not
being loyal it feels like because I feel
betrayed it's true
that I wasn't attracted to you when we
got married and Christine oh she's got
some thoughts to hear that he wasn't
attracted to me it was terrible to hear
and it's super embarrassing right I just
got to thinking you know what
it really just goes both ways I
literally just wasn't attracted after I
said that I was kind of like oh well
then I'm done and it's over it was
almost a relief
well then I'm not going to keep fighting
for this I'm not going to keep trying
and I'm not going to keep doing this if
you're not attracted to me but it was
when Cody called out Christine's
behavior that really grinded her gears
do you believe the lack of Attraction is
an excuse just for your bad behavior or
was it the bad behavior that led to the
lack of Attraction I don't know what
that statement just made me
really yes I'm not a child and your wife
you don't talk to me like that my bad
behavior that's just insulting please
I'm an adult
that's just rude and belittling
no I have dairy I was Furious it's more
like a personal
strength that I feel like I have more
than I've ever felt before because I was
able to make steps for my future and for
my present and so I just feel more
confident as well not only has Christine
found her voice she's also found her
happiness a year after their split I
started moving forward and I just don't
I don't I didn't look back I never
looked back I just started moving
forward EG spoke with Christine in
October she told us she's dating but
nothing serious yet when it comes to
finding a new partner she's looking for
a few important qualities kindness
um real just kindness in a romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that
[Music]